we have seen how we can construct 30 60
and 120 degree angles individually
but here we will try to draw all three
angle measures together in one diagram
here's a glimpse of what we're about to
see
we draw the initial arm of the angle
here
keep the compass at the end point of the
ray
choose a compass width a little more
than half the measure of this length
and draw an arc here
with the compass width unchanged we now
draw an arc here
and again with the compass width
unchanged we draw one big arc here
that's it
we draw three rays at the arc
intersections and get 30 60 and 120
degree measures
simple wasn't it
don't worry let's erase this and look at
it step by step
let ray bc be the initial arm of each of
the angles we plan to construct
first let us draw a 60 degrees angle
we keep the compass at point b
and with a length little over half this
length we draw an arc from above point b
intersecting ray bc at point d
in the next step without changing the
width of the compass
we keep it at point d and draw an arc
intersecting the previous arc at point a
then we join points b and a which gives
us a ray ba
the measure of angle abc will be 60
degrees now getting the 30 and 120
degree angles is quite simple
we keep the compass at point a
and draw a big arc like this which
intersects the previous two arcs at
points e and f
if we join points b and e to get angle
ebc
it will measure 30 degrees
angle abc measures 60 degrees
and angle ebc measures 30 degrees to get
the 120 degree angle we join points b
and f to get angle fbc
the measure of angle fbc will be 120
degrees
so with the base angle being 60 degrees
we constructed two more angles
half that of 60 degrees and twice that
of 60 degrees